[Musique]
et
la résolution du sénat rationné le temps
de la mobilisation pour les
parlementaires de toutes les démocraties
voler au secours de l'arménie
constituée en effet pour nous un
impératif d'humanité l'arménie est le
premier royaume chrétien
de l'histoire de l'humanité
ça n'est pas la même chose d'être un
petit mouchoir de roche perdu au milieu
des empires selon qu'on soit le premier
royaume chrétien et selon qu'on ne le
soit pas on est un avant poste pour
prendre un vocabulaire militaire
on est un bivouac d'éclaireurs quand
l'échauguette ondes c'est la citadelle
qui est menacé c'est très étonnant le
sénat mais à part que dans le pays les
institutions politiques et médiatiques
et considérer ce problème arménien avec
tant d'indifférence nous avons éprouvé
quelque chose qui est l'incroyable force
de la représentation de ce qu'est la
france alors je sais bien que nul n'est
prophète en son pays mais c'est quand
même dommage de devoir faire des
milliers de kilomètres pour tout à coup
rencontrés dans l'oeil de ses semblables
une vibration une émotion à la simple
évocation du mot de france ça c'est la
représentation de la france la france
c'est qu'elle a une représentation
il faudra aussi qu'elle ait une volonté
je crois que son que son intérêt serait
peut-être de s'occuper de l'éternel des
liens et mémorielles des liens
intangible il n'y a pas que le produit
intérieur brut est aussi la vie
intérieure dans la vie moi je voudrais
que la france se montre digne de
l'espoir qu'elle fait naître dans
certains coeurs et dans certains cas
arménien et cet espoir dont elle ne sait
même pas quel le suscitent les arméniens
c'est un peuple phare c'est à dire que
dans l'obscurité il ya une lumière qui
est là et qui va si les qui nous dit il
se passe des choses dans cet endroit du
monde qui nous renseigne sur ce qui
risque d'arriver un peu plus tard
bientôt peut-être plus vite que prévu
dans cette europe qui s'effondrent elles
aussi c'est un peu de l'europe qui est
là bas c'est un peu de la civilisation
judéo chrétienne qui était même plus
qu'un peu que la civilisation judéo
chrétienne qui se trouve là bas donc je
trouve moi qui lis a effectivement à
dire qu'il ya là quelque chose qui se
passe qui engage l'humanité
je le dis l'humanité c'est la question
de l'avenir de la civilisation judéo
chrétienne qui se posent je me demande
combien
d'arméniens devront payer de leur vie
donc le peuple arménien soit aujourd'hui
libre debout et en paix c'est le
génocide qui se poursuit il est clair
que le comportement des autorités
l'azerbaïdjan soutenu par les autorités
turques mais aussi du pakistan mais
aussi de l'entité de chypre nord ont une
volonté d'épuration du peuple arménien
je pense que nous devons honorer cette
culture arménienne dans sa richesse avec
le monde slave et le monde
moyen-orientale je crois que l'arménie
est grande dans cette culture les grands
dans ses souffrances les grands dans sa
mémoire nous devons être résolument à
côté d'elle est d'ores et déjà 40
kilomètres carrés du territoire arménien
et déjà aux mains de l'azerbaïdjan et je
pense qu'il ya là un sujet sur lequel il
faut taper cd revenir pour dire que non
le problème du statut du haut karabakh
n'est pas réglé et tant qu'il ne sera
pas réglée il n'y aura pas de solution
au problème il n'y aura pas de paix
possible pendant cette guerre des 44
jours un accord a été signé entre trois
pays ces pays sont la turquie le
pakistan l'azerbaïdjan et concerne quoi
un accord schollen wing un accord
solennelle qui concerne quel territoire
eh bien ça concerne le cachemire chypre
et le haut karabagh
nous sommes européens et nous sommes
dans l'otan comment aujourd'hui tolérer
une chose pareille comment imaginer
qu'un pays membre de l'otan ait pu
attaquer un autre pays parce que on
parle du karabakh mais aujourd'hui on a
bien conscience que c'est l'intégrité
même de l'arménie qui est en jeu et le
silence des européens est assourdissant
quand nous avons entendu les propos de
notre ministre des affaires étrangères
qui est le ministre de mon pays la
france que j'aime proclamer que la
france
devait rester neutre les bras m'en sont
tombés neutre mes amis cette neutralité
ce n'est pas une faiblesse vous le savez
je n'ai pas une simple indifférence
c'est une lâcheté car type le croire
qu'il peut imaginer un seul instant
que monsieur alief monsieur erdogan
vont stopper tout net leurs exactions
comme en 1915 aujourd'hui encore cent
ans après le génocide c'est en cours la
survie de la nation arménienne sur ses
terres ancestrales qui est en jeu
monsieur le président
chers sénateurs très chers amis je
souhaite vous réaffirmez de tout coeur
la très chaleureuse profonde et profonde
reconnaissance de l'arménie pour votre
engagement pour votre amitié qui nous
est éminemment précieux et sachez aussi
infiniment vital j'exprime ma plus
profonde reconnaissance à la france de
son amitié et de l'extraordinaire
solidarité avec l'arménie et le peuple
arménien vive la france vive l'arménie
est vive l'amitié franco arménienne
mais